[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey uh i have a pretty fun class
prepared for you tonight i want to go
over some uh pretty famous kasparov
games in which he took down the queen's
gambit declined and hello oliver who's
just walking in
uh and so i want to look at this plan
that gary kasparov was was famous for
playing um i don't know if he's he's
he's probably not the first person to to
play it or popularize it but he played
it enough and won enough chess games
that the name kind of stuck a lot of
people call it the kasparov plan
so to start with we're going to look at
this game between kasparov and olf
anderson
of course we start with d4 knight f6
c4
and e6 and i actually want to pause for
a brief moment here if you've played
much chess you've probably seen this
position before uh it's one of the most
common positions right out of the
opening
and you might know that the two most
common moves are knight c3 and knight f3
so
who can tell me why a lot of people
these days are playing knight f3
anybody in the audience what are they
trying to avoid
with knight f3
you might know this one oliver
there's an opening that gives white a
lot of problems
that uh that white's trying to avoid so
not not quite bishop g5 we're looking
for an opening for black and so what
does knight c3 allow let me uh let me
phrase it a little differently what
openings can black choose from here
and yeah the youtube chat does have it
so the nimzo indian um this move bishop
b4 before black has committed this move
d5
a lot of top grand masters these days
aren't so happy allowing the nimzo
indian they think it lets black kind of
equalize um so you see a lot of top
grandmasters play this move knight f3
uh but today we are actually going to be
looking at this knight c3 move order uh
this is actually what i have in in my
repertoire because i'm not so afraid of
the nimzo india i quite like this f3
line and i'm sure you you might have
seen uh one of the numerous lectures
i've taught on that but today we're
going to look at
this line
with d5 and we're going to see
why this move order can actually be
advantageous for white because if it
were as simple as you know allowing the
nimzo or not allowing the nimzo if it's
all going to be the same in the ends
then probably you just shouldn't allow
the nimzo indian right like why not play
knight f3 and just not allow bishop b4
that yeah right there how does that
stop the nimzo
yeah so the the key point of the nimzo
is that after bishop b4 we're actually
pinning this knight to the king and this
is going to be a problem for for white
to deal with in the opening obviously
white has many many options here but uh
this immediate pin
on the night is what leads to these
variations where black is getting
equality just a little bit more easily
than uh for example in something like it
goes
because here black has already committed
to this move d5 and that limits his
options a little bit
uh so by playing knight f3 now if if
black were to try to say the same thing
this would be a perfectly acceptable
move but for example white doesn't have
to step into the pin like i could play
something like bishop d2 and step out of
it so so that's the idea
behind knight f3
so what is the point of playing knight
c3 well the point is after d5 if black
does not play the nemzo indian then we
are actually going to have a really
interesting
option here we can play the kasparov
plan against the queen's gambit declined
and we'll see it's really important that
we have not yet developed this night out
to f3
so what is kasparov's plan well first
and foremost he actually exchanges on d5
and we're going to be looking at e takes
d5 today knight takes d5 is a playable
move but this one is it does get a
little scary for black because white is
able to build
a pretty big center right away so e
takes d5 is more natural
then we're going to come out with bishop
g5 get the bishop outside the pawn chain
c6 is always a good move for black you
want to shore up the the d5 pawn a
little bit
and then here kasparov plays an early
queen c2 so why is white playing queen
c2 here instead of something like uh e3
for example what is uh what is kasparov
hoping to avoid with this move order
diving into all the little subtleties
here
so not quite castling but uh queen c2 is
preventing a really nice developing move
that black wants to play
so after e3
you know what developing move might be
allowed by not having this queen on c2
yeah oliver
um
not g5
this square is g5
bishop g4 well bishop g4 is playable
here anyways right
and i mean it's it's playable in this
position as well so the move is actually
uh bishop f5 which you might not expect
at first glance because it looks like
white's going to have a really nice move
here in the form of queen f3 it's going
to attack this bishop and it's going to
put a lot of pressure on this knight on
f6
but amazingly it turns out that black is
is probably not doing so badly uh in
this line
where the queens come off the board and
even though your pawns look sort of
awful a lot of work has been done here
and black tends to get in equal position
so
the reason why uh kasparov plays queen
c2 here is it just cuts out that line
altogether and these are the the little
opening subtleties that kind of get
skipped over when when you just see
these games kind of off the cuff so
queen c2 here and the idea is to stop
this early bishop f5
okay olaf anderson continues developing
normally then with bishop e7 and now
it's finally time for us just to just
play e3
get developed black's going to develop
the knight because we don't have this
comfortable bishop f5 move anymore now
we go bishop d3
castles and then here the key point is
that it was really important that we
didn't put our net on f3 because
kasparov's plan is to actually put this
knight onto e2
now who can guess why we want this
knight on e2 rather than the more
natural square of f3 because
looking at the knight alone really looks
like we would like to control the e5
square help defender bishop and
potentially play something like 95
someday so what's the point why is this
knight on e2
what's kasparov aiming for here
uh yeah so long castles is going to be
an important idea that we'll see here
but uh the idea is is actually not to
push the f pawn sort of just down the
board like f4 f5
it's more about controlling this key
square on e4
if you're familiar with the carl's badge
structure which is what we have here
just talking about the pawns alone
you might know
especially if you've seen some of my
lectures about the minority attack you
know you you push these pawns on the
queen side you try to take on c6 and
create a weakness
and that's sort of the quote unquote
standard way of playing the position and
that's the type of plan you would go for
after something with with like knight f3
you would want to play rook b1 push this
pawn forward and again try to make a
weakness on the queen's side instead
with knight e2
we're actually going for an entirely
different plan
white's idea is to not play f4 but just
play f3
and we can actually play f3 and still
castle king's side we're not like
wrecking our king or anything uh or you
know potentially we'll see that castle's
queen sight is played sometimes
the point of f3 is actually just that
kasparov wants to to push down the
center of the board and actually use
this extra central pawn that he has this
e pawn where black doesn't have one and
he wants to use this to get a space
advantage in the center he can build
just a big center uh he's hoping that
the black pieces will run out of squares
and things will start to fall
and that is the the crux of this plan so
we see all these opening subtleties we
allow the nimzo indian with knight c3
because we don't yet want to commit our
knight to the f3 square then we saw this
queen c2 move preventing this early
development by black and then we're just
finishing our development here with
knight g to e2 so all those different
little move order subtleties are are
coming together
so now we get the move rook to e8
very common idea black's pieces are a
little bit cramped and this move
actually
allows them to get access to the
critical f8 square to potentially
reroute open up this bishop
and there's potentially another idea
that that black has in mind that i
wanted to mention so after castles
i want to ask you
uh
if you've heard of this like lasker
freeing maneuver in these positions this
one's sort of a deep cut but lasker had
a nice freeing idea that you would
especially see if this knight were on f3
so
imagine this knight's on f3
and do you know a good freeing plan for
black here what do i mean by freeing
well i mean black's pieces are really
cramped he would love to trade some
pieces and potentially occupy the center
but you need to do it in a pretty clever
way
so let's see if you know the alaska plan
yeah oliver what do you think
[Music]
the night we're on f3 uh what what move
yeah knight e4 so
knight e4 and then what's actually
happening here
that you might not expect
yeah that's exactly right this is sort
of the point of the lasker idea is that
it looks like it's sort of suicide to
bring this knight to e4 it's attacked
three times and only defended once by
the pawn so you would expect to be
losing some some material here but
actually
it's important that that this bishop on
uh g5 is attacked if we were to take on
e7 we can play queen takes e7 and then
actually we have just enough defenders
of our knight on e4 to not be losing
material
but in this case thanks to our move
order this is actually not going to be
uh the best move uh after all for black
in this position
uh and i want to show you a really fun
tactic that you might not expect so
you can start with bishop f4 i believe
actually so bishop f4
and now all of a sudden uh black sort of
has this problem with this knight here
on e4
if you were to take on c3 you might even
be running into bishop takes h7 uh i'm
not so sure but
uh
yeah let's say bishop takes h7 king h8
and then i'm
sort of ad-libbing a little bit here but
i think my point stands so knight takes
c3 then i want to ask you what happens
after g6 there's the obvious sacrifice
which might be good for white there's
actually a really nice tactic here
that's uh is rather uncommon
okay i lied i don't want to do it in
this position i'll show you a different
position let's say uh
black just brings this knight back to f6
and claims that you know he unpinned his
piece and that's a success
see if you can find a nice tactic here
and yeah hello to the youtube audience
and the youtube audience already has it
there they're too too clever for me
hello to redox in the chat
so really fun tactic here and it really
just highlights how clustered all these
black pieces are and how in the way of
each other they're they're sort of
getting
this position is actually just dead lost
for black by the way
it's over
oliver i know you've got a tactical
mindset
you've tricked me before
can you trick black here what do you
think oliver
yeah knight b5 this move is nasty very
very difficult to deal with um the point
is this queen is actually kind of
checkmated uh to borrow the word if you
take this knight bishop c7
and the queen is
literally in a box it is boxed in as
bogstan can be and that's going to be
the game
of course if you sort of deal with this
problem somehow by giving the queen a
square
things aren't going to get much better
for you after just something like knight
c7
and even knight e6 here with the double
attack
what's the question oliver
knight b6 same same problem we're just
gonna go knight c7 and you've got uh got
all these issues to deal with so just
wanted to highlight that this last car
plan is is actually not going to be so
good here
uh on top of that white can do other
things and probably keep a slight
advantage even capturing here uh can be
quite nice for for white
generally black would want to take on g5
but that's actually not going to work
here because we can take on h7 with
check and pick up an extra pawn
so black would have to take on e4
and then even after takes on e7 takes on
e7
uh black's just gonna have to struggle a
little bit to deal with this pawn on e4
and now this wouldn't be as much of a
concern if our knight were on f3 because
black would be winning some time you
know attacking this knights and uh
along along with other ideas
so the point is this freeing idea of
knight e4 isn't going to be so good for
black here uh which is why black tries
to potentially prepare it with this move
knight f8 now a lot of those problems
that we saw
for black are going to go away for one
he's defending his h7 pawn and if we
were to play some kind of slow move 94
might actually be a good idea now
if we take can take here no longer is
this a threat and bishop f4 actually is
is coming without a threat you know our
queen has space now has space to move
around
um so of course what move is it time for
what is it time for here
yeah so the problem is uh black has two
defenders here so we're not going to be
able to win tactically anymore
black played nice and solid
ben feingold would never that's my hints
ben feingold would never play this move
ben simon has the answers so
we we want to stop black from freeing
his pieces like this this lasker idea is
actually a pretty nice way to just you
know
solve those early opening problems for
black get the pieces in the game and
deal with your lack of space so we're
just going to play f3 and quite directly
stop this knight from jumping into e4
now of course none of the tactics are
going to work out for black anymore
there's no fancy tricks we just take on
e7 and then take on e4
no time for in-between moves because
your queen is attacked
so f3
comes on the board for gary kasparov
and uh you start to see how
uncomfortable these games can can be for
black unless you're very very confident
in what you're doing because not only
are we advancing our plan right we're
making progress towards playing e4 but
it seems like at every turn whenever
black is is close to to freeing his
pieces with something like knight to e4
he kind of gets shut down just by a
single tempo so important that you don't
waste time in an opening like this even
though it seems kind of relatively you
know tame or calm compared to you know
open sicilians or whatever but time is
always going to be important in chess
so f3 now
and black's not going to give up of
course he comes up with this move bishop
to e6
so
black's ideas to to free himself on the
king's side have sort of uh faltered at
this point so black instead of settling
for bishop e6 which is defending this d5
pawn sort of over protecting this piece
to borrow
nimsovich's uh terminology so
what does this move sort of signal you
know you might be able to see it coming
from from a waste away why
why would black want to defend this pawn
uh a whole lot
looking to break into the center
yeah that's exactly right we need this
extra defense of d5 because uh before
white gets off the ground with with e4
black is trying to play this move c5 at
some point and
sort of open things up and get some
activity for himself so with that in
mind
uh what improving move can we make that
sort of discourages this move
c5
i'll give you hints um all these pieces
are are in pretty good position here so
it's time to bring in the rooks
what do you think oliver
no no not e4 so we'll talk about why e4
is not good yet but we want to keep it
simple we want to continue preparing
uh this break in the center
and we can do so with uh
just a nice developing move a3
uh okay so a3 i don't know if that's
going to be quite enough i think uh
you i think your heart's in the right
place uh against rook c8 what did you
want to do
yeah so i think this would be a great
idea if white were able to get this sort
of lock on the c5 score like this um i
think this would be great but
the problem is i think black's going to
meet you uh on a3 with something like a5
and then b4 is going to be a little bit
too hard to uh to manufacture here
um if you try to prepare it more uh i
think
you might just end up wasting a little
bit too much time and
i don't know what's even a move like
knight six to d7 um and you're sort of
heading in the wrong direction mixing
ideas a little bit this a3 b4 stuff is
good
uh when our knights on f3 but here we're
focusing more on the center more on the
center
so that's actually my favorite move in
the position um rick ad1 i think in this
game kasparov chose the other one
yeah casprov did choose the other one
but i like this move rook ad1
so what does this do to discourage c5
well well let's take a look let's say
something like rook c8
we'll see that king h1 is a good move
and i'll explain why in a little bit
and c5 uh so so what is our point why is
our rook on d1 how does this discourage
c5
h7 with an attack on whatever piece
mine's up there if it's a major it's
actual minor piece or something
um okay i'm a little confused oh okay
bishop takes h7 with the rook on the d
file so
that's one of the tactical ideas in the
position but more basic than that we're
going to look to open the d file and
we're happy to have our rook on this
newly opened file so this is the kind of
anticipation that that really helps you
decide where to put your pieces you
think what is my opponent going for and
you think where is the best uh spot to
put my pieces to sort of combat that
idea
so rook 81 is is my choice for the
position but kasparov in this instance
actually chooses to go
rook a to e1 instead which is also just
a perfectly fine move but i like
discouraging c5 a little bit more
because i think it's a very human plan
you know it turns out that
these positions for black
um let's say king h1 c5 these positions
turn out to just not be so good for
black we can play something like knight
to d4 and it turns out our pieces are a
little bit too active this pawn's a
little bit too weak and white's going to
be a bit better but i think it's a very
human way to play which is why i like
rook d1
instead though we get rook a to e1
and uh black follows up with
rook to c8
and again we're going to play this move
king to h1 so i think it's time to stop
and talk about oliver's suggestion here
uh why are we playing all these sort of
preparatory moves why aren't we just
busting through the center with a move
like e4
what do you think black's idea is going
to be in in these positions
you know why waits why all the
preparation why not just break in the
center
so this looks kind of scary for black at
first looks a little bit scary
so the chest pointing out some important
ideas they're noticing that uh d takes
e4 is an important option for black
and that's going to be an important
option for a couple of reasons
so let's stick with this move first so
what does this move do for black
well it opens the d file which is going
to let black put a little bit of extra
pressure on this d-pawn
notably we only have this pawn defended
one time so this pressure might actually
become important um and secondly
how would like how would white like to
recapture this pawn on e4 with the
knight the bishop or the pawn
yeah of course the pawn you want to
build this strong central duo but taking
with the pawn actually undefends a
really important square in the position
so what square is that and what is
black's big idea here
because if black doesn't have an idea we
would love to do this love to have these
central pawns love to have this open f
file
and just kind of crush
knight
yeah knight g4 sets up a fork like you
said and
on the surface that seems a little bit
artificial right seems like a one move
threat obviously white's not going to
hang the fork
uh but it turns out that this is
actually a really difficult move uh to
deal with for example let's say we take
let's say queen takes
now you have to deal with this threat
somehow you don't really want to play
queen to d2 i guess you could play
something like uh rook to f3 but already
you know you're you're getting a little
bit uh uncomfortable here
with white you're getting a little bit
uncomfortable a lot of threats are
happening over here
uh
on the king's side directly and i'm
gonna cheat a little bit so i don't
embarrass myself um okay queen h4 is not
a good move but okay the other idea c5
is is really really important
and you see that's um
we don't have enough defenders
of our d pawn and so our dark squares
start to fall so for example something
like d5 seems very very natural but now
all of a sudden you're giving up all
sorts of squares and black has ideas
like
c4 here
takes okay and even takes and this
bishop is amazingly kind of trapped but
ideas like queen to c5 are going to be
very important as well and the dark
squares are are very very quick to sort
of collapse in the position once you
break through with e4
so for those reasons that's why you see
preparatory moves like rook to e1 and in
my instance i like rook to d1 because it
just gets to the heart of the problem it
helps defend our weak d4 pawn but rookie
won by kasparov and then even this move
king to h1
so from a long distance away kasparov is
anticipating ideas of this diagonal
becoming weak once we loosen up our dark
squares and ideas of stuff like naiji
for as well so he sees these ideas
coming and he's playing these
preparatory moves and the reason why
white has the luxury of doing this is
he's got a really nice hold on the
position
you know black's only idea here uh to
get active is to play this move c5 and
that move's not going to be so good
as we've seen and so since we have this
nice grip on the position
uh black sort of just has to to let us
uh do what we want in in the position so
why wouldn't we spend all of our time
improving all of our pieces because here
uh white's moves to prepare for the
break in the center are just more
effective than blacks because we have a
little bit more space you see all these
pieces in each other's way and white's
pieces coming to very natural squares so
that's why we spend so much time
preparing the move e4 because we can
afford to you know black's not really
getting active
and we are are happy to spend the time
so
with black you're in a rather difficult
position here uh you don't have this
knight e4 idea we've seen that these
ideas with c5 just aren't going to be
good enough knight d4 is good um this
would be a symmetrical structure by the
way but the two bishops are going to be
very advantageous for whites and if you
don't take well we just have all this
pressure our bishops open our knight is
threatening to jump in and this pawn is
going to be weak in in the long term so
good position for white so if you don't
have c5 you don't have freeing ideas
like knight e4
you start to ask yourself well what do
you do here
so i'm gonna ask you that question what
do you think of anderson came up with
what did olf come up with here
so we've sort of been talking about this
principle indirectly but when you have
less space it's good to trade pieces
because the fewer pieces you have
uh the less cramped you feel in that
small space they don't get in each
other's way anymore and you can move a
bit more freely all right what do you
think oliver
well it's black's turn
and black wants to trade pieces
but yeah for white bishop takes f6 would
be a big mistake
for a lot of reasons
yeah so knight g4 isn't going to quite
work out tactically we can still take on
e7 you don't even have time to take on
e3 because we can just take your queen
uh but you've got the right idea you
need to deal with the pressure on this
diagonal
we've talked about 94 and the reason why
this isn't any good is because remember
we played this move f3 specifically to
stop this idea
but what if you played a move with the
knight that didn't hang the knight
yeah and just just knight uh six to d7
is is what alf anderson played in the
game
and it's not a bad idea but it turns out
that
you know whenever you're moving in the
wrong direction like this whenever
you're retreating like this obviously
you give up some control over central
squares and
yes you get to trade some pieces but
it's going to let kasparov maneuver a
little bit
even more freely than he could before so
bishop takes on e7 queen take or rook
takes on e7 is actually what uh olf
anderson goes for here
and here i think kasparov could finally
get away with something like e4 i don't
think e4 is a bad move at all in in this
position
and let me make sure i'm not missing
something obvious
e4
yeah you can finally get away with it
and it's not a bad idea but again black
is ready at any moment to to break
through with with c5 and again you don't
really want to play d5 just yet uh
because of these these tricky ideas with
c4 and also you're just giving up this
this e5 square
um so we could play e4 but we're not
quite happy with it yet so kasparov
actually prepares it even further with
knight to f4
then after rook to c7 kind of a weird
move but he's actually connecting his
rooks in a weird way
and then uh gary finds this nice idea of
queen to f2 so remember our problem in
all the variations
wasn't the e4 square we have that square
very well defended but we were a little
bit short on defenders of our d4 pawn so
queen f2
helps defend this pawn a little bit and
now after knight to f6 the time is
finally right we've dealt with these c5
c4 tactics we our bishop has flight
squares
and we're finally ready now to break
through with with e4
again this knight g4 idea isn't even
going to be
much of a problem as as we'll see so e4
finally comes through
uh in the game alf does capture
and we're going to take back with the
pawn
and let's see if you can find uh what's
going on after something like night g4
so
we were worried about this move earlier
but what's the story now
yeah so queen g3 what happens if uh
black does end up taking
all right our guy
h3
um okay so you can play age
um i was thinking you might try to go
for something like this knight takes e6
idea
removing the defender of of the knight
but after knight takes it's actually
still going to remain a little bit
a little bit complicated here because if
you take the knight it's going to take
on d3
and i'm not totally sure what's going on
here
not totally sure what's going on here
so we do have to be a little careful
here
would you like to move the queen over to
h4 and set up a pawn push to threaten
checkmate
i'll show you how well that turns out
yeah so i think it might be a little bit
too slow um
for example this knight does still
defend our bishop now so you could play
something like e5
uh
oh boy but i think i think knight g6
should be okay this well first of all
okay this doesn't even threaten
checkmate but knight g6 would be a good
way to free but maybe
maybe the answer is even more simple we
just take and this is still defended
uh so i think surprisingly uh the move
queen to g1 is is a really nice idea
here
the chat pointed out knight takes e6 but
unfortunately this move is is check so
that one that one will get us but yeah i
think just queen g1 and white is still
doing well yeah you just go queen back
to g1
and again the move king h1 actually
comes in handy it's all about these dark
squares whenever you play e4 very very
rarely will the e4 pawn be the problem
it's about uh
making sure you have those dark squares
under control
and white's just doing uh doing well
here so
a couple things to look out for before
you can play the e4 break you have to be
aware of this c5 c4 plan make sure you
have something ready against that you
also have to be aware of this move
knight g4 make sure you're prepared to
meet that effectively
uh and if you can deal with those two
things and it looks like everything is
holding together then the time might
finally be right to uh to play the move
e4
so here knight f6 we're finally ready
with e4 now in the game olf does capture
we take back with the f pawn
uh
i guess it's important to point out what
happens if black doesn't capture
well first of all it's kind of hard to
play a move but
uh
secondly we're just gonna break through
with e5 open up this diagonal and then
our plan becomes very simple we push the
f pawn down the board and black is is to
be in deep deep trouble
so takes on e4
f takes e4 we get rook cd7
and now d5
and
uh
it's it's all about calculation from
this point once you play e4 your grip on
the position is sort of going away the
files are going to open up the black
pieces are going to have things to do
and so you have to be ready to sort of
strike while the iron is hot as they say
so e4
takes takes rook to d7 black already has
a lot of pressure here
um i guess it it might be possible to
try to play a slower move like knight
back to e2 knight fe2 just defending the
pawn but you don't really want to allow
things like c5 and trying to open up
open things up again so
d5 for white is is good it opens up this
diagonal and believe it or not uh
kasparov isn't joking about taking an a7
pawn you know a pawn is a pawn
and in the game we actually get c takes
d
a nice little inner meso with bishop to
g bishop to b5 this is why this tactic
kind of works
rook takes or sorry rook
back to c7 and now we can take on on d5
bishop d7 in the game of course what
happens if
we do get carried away
and try to to take on d5
what happens to black here
yeah i think the youtube chat has the
right idea
these are just uh unfortunately placed
pieces for black and we can pin them up
with uh with rook to d1
um you might be able to throw in knight
takes first and then rook d1 but
actually no you probably don't want to
allow things like rook e5 so
just rook to d1
and the knights pins and there's no way
to uh to save everything for black you
can sacrifice the rook i guess to try
and keep it together
but even here it's very difficult to
unpin you can't really move this queen
away otherwise we're gonna take so deep
trouble for black there and so gary
kasparov calculates his way
uh to this position where the d-pawn is
going to survive it's now actually a
past pawn
and black is in a lot of trouble so what
happens if we try to fork black with d6
first of all
is olf anderson just a dummy did he just
hang the pawn fork
spoilers old fanderson's not a dummy
unfortunately
yeah just uh the simple tactic group
takes on e1 and this rook is no longer
uh well both rooks are are no longer
attacked so you can
uh save this piece
um so no d6 we would much rather have
this pawn on d5 where it uh harasses
this knight on e6 and controls these uh
important squares for black so instead
kasparov just retreats the bishop and
keeps the grip
uh we get rook back to c8 now after
bishop b2 this was a threat of course
uh rook c8 and then kasparov finally
takes on a7
and from here we see b6 and
d6 is a nice sacrifice this is
gaspar of being kasparov but this is a
little bit beyond the scope of the class
uh gary wins the b6 pawn now trades the
queens and goes into this winning end
game which of course you know gary is is
able to win because he's he's gary just
pushes the pawn and olf anderson resigns
but the point i wanted to focus on was
this beginning stages here we saw all
these intricacies this queen c2 move
order
um this f3 idea stopping knight e4 in
its tracks making sure we always had
these freeing maneuvers in mind for
black
and then eventually these preparing
moves keeping in mind the knight g4 and
the c5 ideas
finally knight f4 and we we break
through with our e4 break at exactly the
right moment pressuring on the queen's
side uh breaking through in the center
keeping these tactical ideas in mind and
that is sort of the crux of the kasparov
plan this is uh pretty much the model
game for for showing off this plan
uh gary did pretty much everything right
in the game
and he got a winning position
because of it so
uh any questions on on this game before
we look at one or two more examples
questions here
would be
when your pins when your
knight is pinned to the queen and you
have a bishop
right here yes so
like everyone that i play will just play
h6 and then
g5 h6 g5 okay
and
what's like a practical game plan to
punish that kind of over extension on
the king's side uh yes so we're actually
going to look at a game where white
castle's queen side um and so
okay let's let's i guess go a bit
further in this game
let's say in a position like this right
um this this might be a good a good spot
to show it so
uh
black has sort of run out of useful
moves right in the game we saw olf comes
up with bishop e6 rook c8 and eventually
unpins with with knight's uh
knight f to d knight six to d7 but let's
say instead you know they they don't
find that plan they go h6 they go g5
um here we're actually probably going to
put this bishop back on f2
and the the problem for black is that
this actually takes away
a lot of squares
in the black position you can no longer
play a move like knight g6 we're just
going to capture that piece can no
longer even uh ever really try to occupy
the f5 square and so white doesn't
actually have to do anything special
here i think our normal game plan is is
still going to be perfectly fine and
it's just that black is going to have a
lot of weaknesses on the king's side so
just to show like an example line
um here i think we can uh
let's say i play king h1
rook c8 e4
um and already i think black is is going
to be struggling a bit for example if
you try uh
knight g4 same idea as queen g1 we can
go bishop g1 if you try c5 i think even
the move e5 and notably our bishop gives
us a lot of coverage now and we're kind
of attacking on these light squares
just to continue let's say they tried
the c4 idea we're just going to occupy
the newly weakened light squares with
something like bishop f5 and
in this line at least black is is just
losing from what i can tell so
in this plan in particular you don't
have to do anything special you just
play your normal plan your bishop has
already made kind of nice little square
here on f2
and uh and i i think this move does
nothing but weak in black's position in
this case now
this idea is obviously going to show up
in
any opening under the sun and sometimes
it's going to be good sometimes it's
going to be bad like here and your
response is going to have to be
different sometimes
but just to show something else let's
say black does it a little bit earlier
in a position like this
say rookie 8
let's continue with f3
knight f8
in this position for example we haven't
castled yet and so ideas like h4
queenside castles
just just to show stuff like this is
going to become a lot more relevant when
you can just
really make use of the g5 pawn use it as
a hook to open things up and attack the
black king
but okay good good question
good question
anything else you guys want to talk
about in these these kinds of positions
before we look at another example what's
up oliver
i have a question over here
for example right now age six yeah okay
well if you were paying attention
we we might have seen this position
okay
so we're fine we can capture this we can
come back let's just say i
take yeah
so
yeah black black can get rid of these
dark squared bishops uh with a move like
knight e8 the problem is when you go
backwards like this it's going to take
up a lot of your
developing time you know you see this
rook can no longer come in and
things are going in the wrong direction
for black it's going to give us time to
play castles something like rookie one
knight f4 f3 e4 and already
same plan as always
um
but yeah this this is a playable line
for for black i suppose but
here especially might make sense to just
keep the bishops on the board as well
and again we we have our game plan we
have our game plan
uh okay let us uh continue on here
um do you want to look at the olf
anderson's attempt at an improvement or
a different uh match up entirely because
kasparov and anderson actually played a
number of games in this opening line
i'll leave it up to you guys i think
there's stuff to learn in both
okay old anderson it is good good talk
everybody all of anderson it is all
fanderson number two the return
um so i was having an interesting
conversation with uh
denis forosh before the lecture here
these two games were actually played in
the same year
both in world cups and i i didn't
understand what was going on turns out
they played a series of world cup
tournaments in a grand prix style in
1988. but okay that aside we have
garrick sparrow against elf anderson
again
we're going to breeze past what is now
uh
common knowledge our opening plan again
caspar goes for the early queen c2 get
bishop e7 e3 knight bd7 bishop d3
and here last time we saw stuff like
castles rookie 8 knight f8 bishop e6
but now uh olf anderson's taking a page
out of oliver's book here he's saying
you know i i don't want to deal with
this bishop at all i'm playing knight h5
early early on and uh it's your job to
show me what's going on
uh so in this case we don't actually
have a comfortable way to keep our
bishop you know we don't really want to
play knight f4 allow things or bishop f4
allow things like knight f4 so we are
just going to trade and we get queen
takes e7
and now i want to ask you about
about black's devious plan so
a very clever person might say okay i
still haven't decided between e2 or f3
for my knight and now that the dark
squared bishops are off the board
that might actually weaken this e5
square a little bit so since black
traded the dark square bishops i think
i'm gonna go knight f3 and sort of
switch my game plans again go after this
this e5 square try and uh make my
opponent feel bad about his life
decisions
but of course black has a nice move here
yeah knight f4 um just taking advantage
of this pin and bishop f1 is is
definitely not uh
not what uh white has in mind and i'm
not sure the continuation here but yeah
it's even something like net f6
and
yeah let's just say knight f6 and
now
white's pieces are getting undeveloped
we don't mind bringing this knight to g6
it's white who has definitely wasted
more time in this opening
so i don't like knight f3 but of course
we can come back with knight g to e2 and
this idea is is gone
so now
black continues being clever and plays
this move g6
so a very very different approach to
what we saw last game so g6
and we'll see what the idea is in a
moment but let's say white keeps it calm
in castle's king side which is perfectly
uh natural black castles king's side
rick
e1
knight d to f6
let's say knight c1
and knight g7 okay so after knight g7
hopefully
you you can see
uh the point of black's play
so what is black intending with knight
to g7
what do you think oliver
well if you go knight f5 white's under
no obligation to take that piece right
yeah so maybe you can improve on that
idea just a little bit
no you had the right idea it's it's all
about the f5 square here um that's why
we play g6 that's why we bring this
knight back to g7
yeah bishop f5 that's the idea so let's
say i play h3 you go bishop f5 and now
the point is this is kind of white's
best minor piece in this opening it's
the bishop on two long open diagonals
looking into the position and black is
going to be very very happy to just take
back with the knight and
fight for these light squares now and
black is doing perfectly fine here so of
course
uh players with the white pieces
uh try not to just directly allow this
plane in the line that we just looked at
rather than h3 i think f3 is normal and
now bishop f5 would be met by e4 i
believe
and so this this is one way to play but
we're going to look at gary kasparov's
idea instead which is against this plan
in particular rather than castling
king's side we're going to use the fact
that black has made some slightly
strange moves uh on the king side we're
gonna try to attack on that side of the
board so queen side castles is white's
idea in this position
uh now you notice you know there's some
dark squared weaknesses in the position
moves like g4 are always going to come
with tempo which by the way there is an
interesting line with g4
i think um
if i can find it here
did i make it up
yeah g4 even here is is a potential move
so
these moves aren't going unnoticed by
white so queen side castles in this game
though is what we're focusing on
we get knight b6 for black uh trying to
reveal this bishop and
occupy some squares on the king on the
queen side now that that's where white's
king is
in the game gary continues right away
with knight to g3 the idea being he's
happy to open up this h file now that g6
has been played weakening some things a
little bit
or in the game we can see knight to g7
and white again is keeping a good grip
over
this uh f5 square making sure that black
is not able to occupy this square
king b1 played in the game is always a
nice move for for white whenever you
castle queen slide c file oftentimes is
going to open up often times your a pawn
is weak and it's just a good idea to
play to play king b1
uh now uh wolf anderson goes for bishop
d7
and we get this weird looking move rook
to c1 so
what's the point of rook to c1
well it's it's not not too deep i think
black is looking to play stuff like c5
and white's looking to to slow this idea
down
now in the game we see queenside castles
by black so rather than castling
kingside
when again you know white's going to
have a lot of ideas to try and open
things up stuff like h4 i think might
already be a good move
um yeah stuff like h4 if you play
something like h5
you do have to be very very worried
about ideas like this we can start
routing more pieces over here
and practically it's going to be
difficult for for black to play
with those weak dark light squares
so castle's queen side instead is the
idea
and now gary actually goes for this move
knight a4
it takes takes king out to b8
and gary is is actually now sort of
attacking over here on on the queen's
side so
a very very different way of playing the
position but it's kind of called for
because of the weird moves that black
plays in the opening to prevent the
natural plan
so in this game we actually get b6
bishop a6 knight e6 and rook hc1
and from here
it is honestly a very different way of
playing the position but it makes sense
with how black is played black spends
time over here on the king's side and
castles his king to the queen side and
that allows white to take this sort of
initiative over here doubling up on the
c file putting pressure on the c file
and giving black a difficult time
okay rook e8 played in the game we're
gonna step off of this uh this line here
we get queen to b3 queen to d6
and then finally uh we're going to see
another reroute
by gary kasparov we get this knight end
to f1 and out to d2 just bringing more
pieces over into the attack
okay knight to c7 bishop back to f1
stepping out of the threat and we'll get
to the point soon i promise g3 bishop g2
uh yet another reroute by gary kasparov
rook c7 h4 rook to d8
and uh coming up here
uh you see that gary again just just
sort of has a grip on the position
so in this case black spends so much
time on the king's side that gary is
able to take over the c file and again
just look at look at black's pieces you
know they're they're stuck behind each
other they're stuck behind the pawns and
white is able to just very comfortably
uh apply all this pressure to to the
black uh the black structure you know c5
is still the only real break in the
position and now after this nice
maneuver of bishop f1 to g2 uh black is
just never going to be able to achieve
it
so in the game we get knight out to f3
and queen a4
and finally now black does break with
this move c5 but this is going to cause
a few too many weaknesses i think we get
knight g5 takes takes bishop b7 of
course we want to open things up over
here we're well prepared for it queen to
f4 now takes takes and at the end of the
day uh gary is just winning tactically
with some extra material once again
and
more pawns on the queen side for white
gary again is able to just win this this
end game uh olf anderson maybe made the
job a little bit too easy by taking on
e5
but it was already kind of hopeless
otherwise rookie seven is coming in and
you have a lot of a lot of trouble
but yeah this end game is going to be
winning for whites uh outside passed
upon is going to be good enough so
sort of zoomed through this game because
we're running very very short on time
and i want to show one more maneuver
uh but what's the key point the key
point is black plays this early knight
h5 move we want to take on e7 play
knight e2 and then there are a variety
of plans here you can go crazy attack on
the king's side you can play king side
castles and try to keep things at bay
with stuff like f3 or you can do what
gary does uh castle queen side and then
if black meets you on the queen side
just look to take over this c file and
again
play um
very preventatively you know stop black
from playing c5 stop black from getting
the pawn breaks that he needs to uh to
free his pieces
um okay and that's the story of this
game so quick questions on this before i
show the last maneuver that i want to
show
okay all right let's move on to finally
the last plan that i want to at least
introduce you guys to
uh for this we're going to look at a
game between kasparov and berua who i've
been told was uh the first indian grand
master i did not fact check that dennis
borders told me so we'll see if he's
right or not don't blame me if i'm wrong
okay queen c2 bishop e7 we're going to
get all the same moves here castles
knight ge2
rookie 8 knight f8 so exactly the same
position
as the first game but here instead of
this bishop e6 rook c8 setup we're gonna
see black go for this move knight to g6
so this one is a little bit uh
a little bit more counterintuitive than
than the other setup you know why bring
this knight to g6 then knight of the f8
and all the other variations was a
fantastic defensive piece keeping the
king's side together
well we'll see black's id in a moment we
go rook ad1
and then black actually plays this move
h6
so what on earth is going on with h6
you know how does this make sense with
with putting this knight on g6 what's
the idea here
yeah it forces the trade of the bishop
for the night so what is what is the
downside what is the downside
yeah you might lose a pawn um but also
of course it just weakens all the
squares even if you don't lose the pawn
so this knight is attacked two times
it's no longer defended by the h pawn
and so after the simple move takes on f6
takes an f6 takes on g6 takes on g6
fortunately for black there's pressure
on e3 so we don't quite have time to
take here
but these are weaknesses that that
aren't going to go away
they're just not going to go away
so with this simplification and the
removal of all the knights uh white is
able actually to play this move e4 just
directly
uh and here we'll see that uh barua was
was not actually able to keep control
over all these light squared weaknesses
in his position
so in the game
he goes g5 and gary now is able to just
expand out with e5 and f4
a plan that we've seen before and after
g takes f4 knight takes f4 uh white is
already gonna be just just significantly
better here you can
do things like occupy the f file this
advanced e5 pawn is going to be very
strong and you can just see how
shattered all of these light squares are
in in the black camp why it's going to
use these occupy these squares and and
get a very nice advantage now rook of 8
was played knight g6 take take bishop e6
but now we just bring in the second
knight
the knight comes into g3 again it's all
about the light squares that's what's
been weakened
and we'll see that the light squares are
so important that black actually gives
up and just sacrifices the rook the rook
for the night
and with that
gary has pretty much a winning advantage
in the game it took him quite some time
to win the game um and maybe he even
blew it at some point but if you're
going to end up up in exchange out of
the opening then your opening went
pretty well
so this was the last little maneuver i
wanted to expose you guys to uh in this
one our plan is going to remain largely
largely the same we're still playing for
e4 still playing for that big center uh
but we're just focusing more on using
these weak light squares in position h6
is just weakening these a little bit too
much and
white is able to break through over
there
by the way in the game this move g5 is
probably what uh ensures that black is
going to be a lot worse if you leave
this pawn on g6 it's going to give you a
little bit of a better chance
for example it takes an e4 takes an e4
and something like bishop g5 might be a
better way of trying because at least in
this instance can't quite get away with
this move e5
as easily
and as for what's going on here well
it's it's what it looks like white has
the big center that's going to try to
keep the big center and uh and use it to
to attack on the king's side attack on
the clean side uh wherever he can find
and provoke weaknesses
okay and with that we are i believe just
in time to uh end the class before alex
lunderman gets here uh if you do have
some more time in person audience do
stick around because uh we've got alex
lenderman fresh from his u.s champs
performance he had a very good
tournament there wasn't quite enough to
end up with the victory
but uh he is our grandmaster in
residence and he will be teaching
believe insane in the end game so this
class is more openings focused if you
want to check out an endgame class stay
tuned for that
and i just want to thank you guys very
much for coming out and learning about
chess with me as always my name is caleb
denby and i will see you next time
thank you
[Music]